New York Times best-selling author Abram
X candy has turned one of his
groundbreaking books about racism into a
graphic novel his 2016 book stamped from
the beginning the definitive history of
racist ideas in America won the national
book award but the book and its
adaptations have been challenged in
several school districts over claims it
tackles divisive topics and employs
selective storytelling now candy and
illustrator Joel Christian Gill are
releasing stamp from the beginning a
graphic history of racist ideas in
America it uses five historic figures
including Thomas Jefferson and Angela
Davis as tour guides to show how
America's past influences its present
Hebrew makes candy also a CBS News
contributor joins us right now how you
doing good morning I'm good good morning
so it's been seven years since you first
released stamp from the beginning why
did you feel like it was time now to
release a graphic novel
well I I just believe in the power of of
graphic novels the the ability of of
comics to tell complex stories even in
in a humorous fashion and I'm just
constantly thinking about ways to reach
Everyday People young people and older
people with this history of racist ideas
yeah the illustrations are beautiful and
they do capture your words so
beautifully
that you also add in humor and some will
say well these are some heavy topics
um how could you tell jokes when
covering stuff like this but Nate that's
what I liked about it though I mean I
was talking to him in the Green Room
about this when they were talking about
Link in the in the Emancipation
Proclamation on page 34 134 you see the
people running they go we out
not we're leaving not let's go but we
talk about the proclamation then it's
like we out and you can see them really
we all enjoy the humor yes but I did I
like it too I thought that was a nice
touch but why did you find that
important to kind of connect those two
things humor and history well you
mentioned the heaviness of it those are
the times in which we need humor right
to to receive it to understand it to get
through it and I think Joel and I
thought that was critically important
and it is a tradition particularly
within black comedy to talk about racism
particularly it's ridiculousness and and
I think that tradition continues in in
this book
you know uh one of the conversations
animating politics today is the question
of racism in America the topic of this
book ideas to go back to the founding
and even before and Republicans on the
campaign Trail will say America is not a
racist country this book would say
otherwise what's your response to that
political conversation
well I don't actually think it should be
up for debate we we live in a country
where this widespread racial disparities
black people are more likely to be
impoverished incarcerated killed by
police dying of heart disease and cancer
and that's not because there's something
wrong with black people that's because
of our policies and practices which
collectively are racism there's a line
in the book here about racial equality
sold as a slow but steady progression
forward which it sounds like you would
say it's not I think people on the right
would say but we need we should also
acknowledge should we not all of the
racial progress and improvements legally
and otherwise so what we try to do in
this book is show both so there has
indeed been been racial progress but
there's also been what I call in my work
the progression of racism so like voter
suppression policies today are much more
sophisticated than they were a century
ago just as you have you know elected
officials of color who weren't in in in
particular positions a century ago both
is happening at the same time right no
you're right that people without racist
ideas were never simply products of
their time which I think is is really on
point especially when we look at how
what is happening in the world today how
should we view figures like the founding
fathers well the founding fathers were
some of them were expressing racist
ideas but there were people challenging
them in their time right you were
talking about Thomas Jefferson
Phyllis Wheatley was challenging that
Benjamin Banneker was challenging them
even a Rhode Island Pastor the name of
Samuel Hopkins was challenging them and
so over the course of history we've had
both racist ideas and anti-racist ideas
and unfortunately people chose to
continue to express ideas of racial
hierarchy it's interesting you'd be here
on the same day that Amanda was just
here in our last half hour where her
book has been restricted in some areas
and some people say your books are not
age-appropriate for children today how
do you respond
I just think it's it's not true I think
that we we create books like others do
that are that are going to be able to
reach children that children are going
to be able to understand in which
they're going to see themselves and
unfortunately particularly Black authors
authors of color lgbtq authors our books
are being banned as somehow not age
appropriate so I mean what does that say
you know I think that's one of the
things that Amanda talked about and and
I could also say that what's really
difficult for me as a parent
is that books are being banned but not
guns yeah but you know I I think one of
the one of the questions people have is
what's the role of school is it to
educate yes but is it also to create a
citizen a patriot of a country who has
it was a stake in that country believes
in it and people on the right will say
well this doesn't make people love
America this is the opposite of that
well if you read stem from the beginning
you'll see figures like Angela Davis and
a whole host of other figures who are
challenging are critically uh this
nation's laws and policies and figures
to transform it to make it better to
ensure that we all could live in a
multi-racial democracy we're all equally
valued and treated equitably no doubt we
appreciate you thank you so much for
stopping by you bro makes candy stamped
from the beginning a graphic history of
racist ideas and America is on sale now